[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition and last night in
select theaters we got our first look at
the upcoming christopher nolan movie
tinette the teaser was shown in certain
cinemas before hobbs and shore
and whilst it hasn't been released
online yet the footage was leaked to
twitter
though it has since been taken down fear
not though i managed to grab the trailer
before it was removed
and throughout this video i'll be
breaking down everything that happens in
it i did originally upload this video
with the full footage but it was removed
so i thought i'd try putting it back
up with just screenshots now there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you don't
want to know anything about the preview
then i highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way i just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
i hope you enjoy it now let's get into
my breakdown of the tinnette
teaser trailer okay so the roughly 40
second long
trailer opens with a fractured bullet
hole against some bulletproof glass
john david washington's character begins
to walk towards it
and on screen we see the words time has
come for a new protagonist
the trailer reverses slightly to show
some seconds of the prior shot and he
once again steps forward
with the words time has come for a new
mission appearing on screen
washington gets close to the bullet and
touches it which is when the music
really ramps up there's a feeling of a
ticking clock to it all and the film is
reportedly going to be heavily time
focused
similar to nolan's prior films inception
momento
interstellar and doug kirk this is also
i'm guessing why time appears so many
times in the trailer
and it looks like we may be getting some
sort of clock bending movie set to the
world of secret agents
and spies washington then walks along
and we see three identical bullet holes
all mirroring the first one and then we
cut to washington line on his back
probably preparing for a mission and
then a man in a gas mask running
then washington's character fighting a
swat team member and then being dragged
away which is when we cut to the title
which spins into the screen
we finish with washington's character
wearing breathing apparatus and then his
face lights up which ends the trailer
okay so there's not a huge indicator
here of what's going on but i have to
say in full swing the trailer looks
incredible
and definitely gets my heart pounding
due to the score i'll probably be doing
a full breakdown when the official first
look releases but i thought i'd just
discuss the leak for the time being but
yeah
it looks great obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on this first look as
well as what you think the film will be
about
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the ending of hops and show
which will be linked after this
the trailer for tonight was shown before
the film so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
if you want to come talk to me about
movies tv shows games and comic books
then you can follow me on twitter at
definition yt it's the best way to get
in touch with me and is the perfect
place to suggest new videos and content
so hopefully i see it over there after
this also just want to let you know that
we're currently giving away a free copy
of avengers end game on blu-ray to one
lucky winner and all you have to do is
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the
net trailer in the comments section
below the one will be charged at random
on august 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are mad into movies
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this i've been definition
you've been the best i'll see you next
time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you